- Un déploiement scénique.
ce petit robot à six roues de
la NASA débarque dans le cttère
Gale sur Mars.
L'euphorie est totale.
Sa mission : tenter de répondre
la planète rouge a-t-elle été
un jour habitable?urur sa route,
l'engin de 900 kg prend des
milliers de clichés, sonde le
détecter la présence de soufre,
d'oxygène,  c carbone -
essentiels à la vie- et de
conclure que la planète rouge
plus de 3 milliards d'années.
ROBERT LAMONTAGNE,
astrophysicien,
- Évidemment, on parle ici de
vie microscopique sous la forme
validé qu'il y avait... qu'il y
a eu de l'eau en abondance,
mais que cette eau était salée,
qu'elle a été là pendant
pour possiblement permettre
l'apparition de formes de e.e.
- Curiosity a roulé sur 28 km,
scrutant notamment collines,
rivières assechés. Sa missiont r
que deux ans. La NASAl'a toutefe
jusqu'en 2025.
Le robot s'apprête à exp s s sl
est essentiellement composé
de sulfates, ce qu'il n'a pas
encore étudié.
AGNÈS COUSIN, Inst. de recherche
- Et voir aussi quel genre de
sulfate c'est, pcece qu'on peut
en avoir plusieurs. Donc, ça
nous apprend aussi le changement
- Et Curiosity n'est pas le seul
à arpenter la surface de Mars.
l'a rejoint l'an dernier
avec pour mission la recherc
de traces prébiotiques et
la collecte d'échantillons
- Ce sera probalement la plus
grande découverte de l'histoire
la vie n'est pas unique
à la Terre.
- D'ici là, la réponse
à cette question existentielle
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canad M Montréa